i wanted to talk to you because i feel
like um
you've kind of become um
one of one of the leaders in this
country kind of by
by default when it comes to just
spreading awareness to what's going on
like and you've
i mean i've been following you probably
for five or six years now and
um you know i feel like what you do
is that's why i get so irked when i see
people trying to come at you i'm like
like this guy's like because you've been
around
you see more context and uh
and you also see kind of the
manipulation of
how people will extract one quote and
extract words from another quote and say
look at this guy he's a hypocrite and
for me i tell you what i'll tell you
what did it for me i was
the i was the senior justice right i
moved my whole family to new york we
moved to brooklyn
and i was the senior justice writer for
the new york daily news
and i wrote hundreds and hundreds of
articles for the paper even
articles that were on the front page
articles that were the most shared
articles
in the in the for the entire paper and
then i would walk around the streets of
new york this is before the pandemic
and people would come up to me and they
wouldn't tell me they read my articles
they would say something like this to me
they would say sean
uh everything i know about the news i
get from your instagram
and at first when people told me that i
freaked out a little bit because
instagram's not really built for that it
wasn't designed to be a news
source and i wasn't running my page to
be a news source
and so i i continued to write my
articles continued to push you know push
forward as a journalist
and everywhere i would go people would
say listen if you don't post it on
instagram i don't see it
and eventually instead of rejecting that
i just leaned into it and said
for better or for worse people are using
this
community and in this source
as how they learn about police brutality
about racism and bigotry
and i have to find smart useful ways to
curate this thing better
to be responsible for it i i'm still
frustrated that we don't have
better news sources for people to lean
into where they can get
current up-to-date information on these
types of issues
but in the absence of it i just leaned
into it and just said
okay let me let me try to do better
and uh share as many stories as i can so
that's me i don't have any help
that's me you know posting them writing
them
i don't have any special apps i'm just
on my phone
chugging along trying to trying to keep
people as informed as i can
and just um holding people accountable
on your page
you know i think the fact that like
i mean look as a white guy in america
who has made his
entire living as a grown up off of the
back of black culture like i've been
involved in hip hop my entire life and
that's how i feed my family you know
um i got a biracial sun um and
you know like i like your page is really
uh something that like you know me and
my wife or
even my son who's 14 he follows you it's
like
well see i get that everywhere man um
everywhere that changed me too
like when someone like you tells me
that you have a child who fought
everywhere i go
i get parents who say hey my kids turn
me on to your page or i get school
teachers who tell me
elementary middle school high school
teachers say
we use your social media as a primary
source
for how we study these issues and it
just caused me to say like okay
this is uh you know social media was
kind of designed for like laughs and
giggles
it was designed for cat pictures you
know it was designed for
for uh you know uh for models
i mean yeah but you know at the same
time it's it's also you know
it's it's awareness yeah and so i tried
to lean into it man
and and so when somebody tells me like
so
i don't take that lightly you know when
when people's children
or students or teachers or professors
are using this as a source
i put a lot of effort into it and uh and
so i see
it's weird as it is and i never imagined
it would be this way like i see the
the community that i have particularly
on instagram
as being my primary way to
inform the world of injustice and i try
to give
people i try not to just tell bad
stories i try to point us to solutions
actions that we can take yeah and so um
it's uh you know you use what you have
you know and i'm i'm trying man